microsoft is going all in on the
metaverse that's right microsoft is not
playing around they are acquiring
activision blizzard for about 70 billion
dollars in all cash baby no stock
microsoft buying activision for 70
billion activision stock is up 37
in the pre-market and it's the largest
acquisition by far in microsoft's
45-year history this will now make
microsoft the third largest gaming
company by revenue behind tencent and
sony when we go ahead and we look at all
of the different acquisitions that
microsoft has made over the years this
one is massive activision is 75 billion
dollars give or take in all cash the
next biggest was linkedin at 26 billion
and then nuance and skype down at 16 and
eight and a half billion when you look
at the size of this this is a bet the
company type movie with microsoft they
understand that the whole idea of these
digital universes the metaverse whatever
you want to call it it's going to be a
big deal in the future
facebook changed their name to meta
microsoft went and bought activision
blizzard now of course if we start to
look at what the hell their plan is you
can think about this in that there's
going to be an intersection of gaming
and also these digital worlds
previously people simply lived in the
digital world in video games but now
those digital worlds are coming to life
for other things are you gonna work in
there are you gonna have social
interactions are you gonna do other
things nobody actually knows where the
world is headed but what we do know is
that companies like microsoft understand
that they have to be a player they don't
have their own physical headsets and so
ultimately what they've got to do is
they've got to go out they've got to
acquire the skill sets whether it's
technical talent actually build these
digital worlds or its existing
intellectual property that they can then
go and they can license or they can use
for their new virtual worlds their new
metaverses this is where the world is
moving and microsoft is not going to be
left behind now if we go ahead and we
look at all of the different brands that
activision owns this is a lot of big
time names call of duty warcraft candy
crush tony hawk diablo overwatch guitar
hero and many many more this is
literally a tier one asset you can go in
and you buy an entire portfolio of the
top gaming names in the entire world
microsoft went and chose very carefully
if you're gonna spend 70 to 75 billion
dollars in cash you can't miss as they
say when you come at the king you can't
miss and that's what microsoft is trying
to do here ceos satya nadala said when
we think about our vision for what a
metaverse can be we believe there won't
be a single centralized metaverse that's
really exactly what mark zuckerberg has
been saying as well these large
companies understand that there's going
to be interoperability there's going to
be open source software but still having
intellectual property like activision
blizzard has also having the
relationship directly with the customer
it's going to be very valuable in the
future now how exactly are the stocks
responding to this type of news well
there's mixed reactions activision
blizzard up big but of course microsoft
down a little bit maybe the legacy
microsoft investors don't really like
the idea of the metaverse but again as
we know returns come from doing the
unpopular things the things on the
fringes way before everybody else it's
very clear facebook microsoft and all of
the legacy large incumbent technology
firms they're going all in on the
metaverse and microsoft just made a 70
to 75 billion dollar bet i hope it works
out for them